[Musica]
è un uovo è solo un uovo quello che
vedete alle mie spalle un uomo come
quello che c'è nel vostro frigorifero e
se non c'è sarà sicuramente sulla lista
della spesa delle cose da comprare entro
domani e un alimento disponibile comune
a basso costo non gli prestiamo più
attenzione non gli attribuiamo un valore
particolare D'altra parte è l'uovo di
Colombo cosa ci sarà da scoprire da dire
su un uovo eppure non è così scontato
l'uovo sappiamo bene che il simbolo di
vita di inizio di rinascita di
rinnovamento e anche se torniamo solo
sulla dimensione personale tutti noi
possiamo associarlo a un momento
un'emozione un ricordo
per me è il gusto del nuovo sbattuto con
lo zucchero il caffè che mi preparava
mia mamma quando ero piccola e mio papà
che ancora oggi racconta delle uova sode
che mangiava Tra le altre cose
all'università a Firenze quando studiava
agraria come ho fatto io dopo di lui
e voi ricordate le uova che cercavamo al
supermercato al tempo del lockdown
quando ci servivano per preparare
biscotti torte crème caramel con cui ci
siamo coccolati e siamo anche ingrassati
e che abbiamo condiviso con i nostri
amici con i nostri familiari anche
online Ecco se anche per voi le uova in
quei momenti in qualche modo hanno fatto
qualche differenza possiamo condividere
il fatto che le uova nella sostanza Sono
una risorsa preziosa sono un concentrato
di nutrienti all'interno del nuovo c'è
tutto quello che serve perché si possa
sviluppare un organismo animale come un
pulcino come un uomo per quantità e
qualità di delle proteine che contiene
dei grassi colesterolo incluso di
minerali delle vitamine e di altri
composti bio
attivi e per queste sue caratteristiche
le uova l'uovo a livello globale può
contribuire a soddisfare i fabbisogni
alimentari e nutrizionali in un contesto
di una dieta equilibrata per quantità e
qualità anche con altri alimenti di una
popolazione che cresce e che continua a
crescere e può contribuire al
raggiungimento di alcuni degli obiettivi
di sviluppo sostenibile che
l'organizzazione delle Nazioni Unite si
è proposta di raggiungere da qui a poco
meno di 10 anni entro il 2030 quali la
riduzione della fame della povertà
benessere salute
questo perché le uova hanno le
caratteristiche nutrizionali di cui
dicevamo perché non ci sono limiti a
livello globale dal punto di vista
religioso e culturale al consumo delle
uova cosa che invece accade per altri
prodotti di origine animale e rispetto
all'ambiente la produzione delle uova e
una produzione più sostenibile rispetto
ad altre produzioni soprattutto per
alcuni indicatori
Ma cosa c'è dietro un nuovo sicuramente
c'è una gallina Ma le uova che
produciamo le uova che sono disponibili
ogni anno A livello mondiale sono
miliardi per cui ci sono tantissime
galline di razze diverse dalla Padovana
con cui si chiude anche l'inaugurazione
dell'anno accademico a Padova con la
goliardia ogni anno ad altri tipi
genetici e questi animali sono adattati
a vivere dal livello del mare fino
all'alta montagna in sistemi che
prevedono meno l'accesso all'esterno con
maggiore o con minore disponibilità di
spazio con attrezzature diverse
Ma quali che siano le situazioni quello
che dobbiamo assicurare a queste galline
come agli altri animali in allevamento è
benessere salute e qualità della vita
quindi noi come ricercatori nel settore
delle Scienze animali anche in
collaborazione con altri colleghi è
sempre con un approccio
multidisciplinare che Integra più
conoscenze più competenze
studiamo ricerchiamo
confrontiamo indicatori oggettivi di
benessere animale che considerino anche
il comportamento e non solo
e che ci permettano di confrontare
diverse situazioni di allevamento e i
risultati delle nostre ricerche sono
messe a disposizione della comunità
scientifica tecnica ma anche dei
legislatore che li utilizzo per
formulare le normative sul benessere
degli animali in allevamento per
aggiornarle anche per le galline
Ma questo non basta anche quando è stato
definito quando la norma definisce
quelli che sono i limiti del sistema che
garantiscono il benessere animale è
necessario avere dei sistemi che in
tempo reale in continuo oggi ci
consentono di controllare la situazione
degli animali dal punto di vista del
benessere e della salute e di
intervenire con misure correttive ogni
qualvolta si renda necessario e per
questo motivo Sempre noi i ricercatori
nel settore delle Scienze animali ci
integriamo con altri colleghi che hanno
competenze diverse per sviluppare degli
allevamenti sempre più tecnologicamente
avanzati si parla di allevamenti 4.0 non
solo industria 4.0
e all'interno di questi allevamenti si
implementano sensori che misurano
diverse variabili il movimento
l'attività di alimentazione i suoni le
vocalizzazioni le condizioni
microclimatiche
si raccolgono la grande quantità di dati
Quindi siamo in un sistema di big data
questi dati vengono processati e
lavorati con degli algoritmi più o meno
complessi come quelli di Machine
Learning per prevenire controllare e
regolare la situazione degli animali in
allevamento
stiamo parlando di intelligenza
artificiale ma come intelligenza
artificiale
applicata agli allevamenti Sì questo e
altro
l'innovazioni la ricerca che si fa nel
settore delle essenze animali si muove
per far sì che gli allevamenti possano
essere sempre più sostenibili in futuro
e quindi abbiamo visto anche se solo
parzialmente insieme come quel semplice
uovo con cui abbiamo iniziato abbia
delle relazioni complesse e molteplici
interazioni con quelli che sono i
fabbisogni dell'uomo dell'animale
dell'ambiente
e queste relazioni devono essere
considerate e valutate in con una
prospettiva che nuova solo nella
definizione ma non nell'urgenza di
essere adottata che prende il nome di
One Welfare benessere globale che ci
dice che possiamo parlare di benessere
solo quando tutte le componenti che
interessano il sistema si trovano in una
situazione di benessere quando questo
benessere è condiviso e trasversale
e quindi
questo uovo oggi l'ho utilizzato per
fare con voi per mettere in evidenza con
voi quella che oggi la necessità di un
ritorno alla complessità
e in un momento in cui la
semplificazione e la regola in un
momento in cui le soluzioni sono spesso
slogan e sono preconfezionati questo
ritorno alla complessità e anche un
elogio della complessità e quello che ci
serve per poter aprire la discussione
per poter fare ricerca e per portare
innovazione
e se torniamo all'uovo col quale abbiamo
cominciato
quel semplice uovo
Dopo quello che ci siamo detti
considerando anche il fatto che
l'uovo è nato prima della gallina
possiamo
lasciarci con la consapevolezza che
quell'uovo quel luogo che avete nel
vostro frigorifero e che ritroverete nel
vostro frigorifero questa sera non è
solamente un uovo
[Applauso]